It's estimated that over 8 million trees
are chopped down every year to make
pencils.
Now this company is making them from old
newspapers, reducing deforestation in
the process.
We are suffering from climate action and the best way is to reduce the number
of trees that are cut for any purpose.
We want each and every child in Kenya who
goes to school to use our pencil and at
the same time be able to plant a tree
through our pencil. That way, we will reduce
the number of trees cut.
We'll also provide an option and reduce
the number of wooden pencils in the
market.
This is how they're made. After
newspapers are cut to size,
graphite is glued to the paper. That's
put into a roller and dried out in the
sun.
Finally, they're put through a
compressor, sharpened and packaged up.
We can address climate change by making
pencil from recycled paper. One,
we reduce the amount of trees cut down when we use recycled paper.
Number two, we reduce the amount of
waste paper that is dumped or burnt.
That way, green pencils made from recycled paper
contribute also to addressing climate
change.